[Música]
hace un tiempo estaba leyendo un
artículo de bloomberg que decía que en
áfrica hay más innovación que en américa
latina'
ustedes pueden creer eso
pues resulta que
hablando con muchos de mis amigos
emprendedores que conozco
llegamos a la conclusión de que aquí en
américa latina' tenemos un ecosistema de
emprendimiento tóxico
y a qué me refiero con un ecosistema de
bueno charlando con estas personas
empezamos a mapear cuáles eran las
características de los emprendedores
aquí en latinoamérica
primero el clásico hago quiero hacer tal
aplicación pero no sé qué es eso de
programar
y el equipo técnico que dice o yo quiero
inventar tal cosa tengo los
conocimientos técnicos pero no es capaz
de ir a preguntar al mercado si eso va a
funcionar
también hay otro tipo de emprendedor el
de las incubadoras a ver cuál es el to
the list para hacer mi empresa ustedes
creen que mark zuckenberg cuando estaba
haciendo facebook dijo junto a mi
mercado van a ser personas de 20 años de
clase social a más
ustedes ustedes creen que pasó eso
cuando marc su permiso facebook
el otro
mi mamá me dijo que mi idea es
fantástica y luego va con el mejor amigo
y a mi hijo al amigo dijo que maría es
fantástica y se las pasan vendiendo sda
una y otra vez pero nunca hacen nada
cuando aparece un emprendedor que parece
que lo va a hacer todo que va a ser algo
magnífico para lo único que se prepara
es para ganar concursos y la mayoría de
los emprendedores en el ecosistema de
latinoamérica se preparan solamente para
eso para ganar concursos y no para
innovar
y
el que no estemos innovando nos está
dejando en una gran desventaja porque
porque la innovación es el motor de la
economía del futuro es más el motor de
la economía actual la mitad de las
empresas más ricas del mundo son de
tecnología son de innovación entonces
necesitamos hacer algo para cambiar las
cosas aquí en latinoamérica porque
tenemos personas capaces personas muy
inteligentes con muchas ideas además
tenemos muchísimos recursos
latinoamérica desde las regiones más
ricas del mundo pero pues no está no se
ve reflejado en ninguna parte en
cuestiones de innovación
entonces yo les vengo a proponer tres
puntos
y podemos aplicar para mejorar el
ecosistema
el primer punto es tiene sus títulos
tienen sus madrinas sus doctorados no va
literalmente pero es para quitarse ese
constructo mental de yo soy abogado por
lo tanto no puedo aprender a programar o
no puedo aprender a diseñar o no puedo
aprender a hacer lo que necesito para
llevar a cabo mi proyecto entonces nunca
paren de aprender si está bien tener un
área de expertise pero también
agréguenle lo que necesitan para hacer
su proyecto es si existe internet
actualmente no hay excusa para no
aprender aunque pongan en internet cómo
hacer tal cosa ustedes pueden aprender a
hacer eso
segundo punto y esto lo dice mi tío y lo
más que se toquen enfoques en algo que
es signo o vengáis signo govern hoy sé
es que se enfoquen en la señal o sea que
dejen de escuchar todo ese ruido que hay
cuando quieren hacer un proyecto a qué
me refiero con ruido a esas
distracciones que los de se enfocan de
sus objetivos actuales en su etapa
actual mucho de lo que pasa en el
ecosistema de emprendimiento actual es
que un emprendedor empieza a ir a
muchísimos eventos de innovación sin
ningún sentido alguno empiezan a empezar
a leer libros ver muchos vídeos en
youtube pero no tienen un foco hacia
dónde van a ir entonces traten de
enfocarse en qué es lo que ustedes
necesitan hoy sino si quieren hacer una
aplicación no saben programar enfóquense
en aprender a programar o al menos
entender cómo funciona para encontrar a
un programador que les ayude a hacer su
proyecto
y tercer punto y es muy importante este
enfoquémonos en hacer productos de
calidad
cuando ven un producto de latinoamérica
la mayoría de las veces cuando lo
comparan con un producto de silicon
valley steve changing es de silicon
valley de china se ve la diferencia
abismal no estamos haciendo productos de
calidad no nos esforzamos por hacer
productos que compitan a nivel
internacional y para esto no hay que
dejar de aprender hay que ver que están
haciendo los mejores y tratar de ser
como ellos no tratar hacerlo
y creo que hay algo más importante más
allá de sus tres puntos tenemos que
enfocarnos en el por qué el por qué voy
a hacer algo
no estoy haciendo porque quiero resolver
un problema
o lo estoy haciendo porque quiero tener
mucho dinero
no estoy haciendo porque quiero hacer el
próximo y el hombre jobs o lo estoy
haciendo porque quiero ser yo mismo
hágase esa pregunta porque quieren hacer
las cosas para ver cuál es el propósito
detrás de todo ello
al menos de mi parte tengo quiero ser
jensen bardot y afortunadamente encontré
un problema un problema que me duele
muchísimo y estoy dispuesto a resolver
mi área de expertise es ser
desarrollador de aplicaciones de
software
y qué sirve ser desarrollador de
software desarrollar software se trata
de solucionar problemas a través de la
computadora es decir abstraigo la
realidad en datos lo introduce con una
computadora y le digo que tiene que
hacer con esos datos para que resuelva
un problema eso es lo que hacemos pero
en el mundo de desarrollo
hay muchísimas cosas que hacer es muy
complejo
cuando estaba estudiando una web de
hecho la facultad de computación el 60%
de los primeros desde el primer semestre
se salió de la facultad porque es hay
muchísimas cosas que hacer es muy
complicado
de alguna manera yo quería resolver
problemas pero la complejidad que
existía me limitaba
es algo similar a la computación de los
60s cuando las máquinas eran gigantescas
y para correr una computadora tenías que
por cierto un edificio lleno de
muchísimas máquinas con muchísima
complejidad hasta que se inventó el
circuito integrado
y el circuito integrado permitió que
ahora tengamos computadoras en nuestros
bolsillos
entonces empezamos a trabajar en algo y
hoy mis socios en un proyecto que se
llama doni
toni
es una plataforma para ayudar a los
desarrolladores a que tengan más
estructura en este mundo de entropía
nuestra misión es que en el futuro con
ayuda de la inteligencia artificial
un desarrollador puede llegar con doni y
decirle tony ayúdame a crear tal
aplicación
y don y te ayude a crear la aplicación
no que te reemplace sino simplemente que
te ayude a resolver problemas a ser más
productivo a enfocarte en lo que
verdaderamente importa
pero bueno para empezar este proyecto
que es ambicioso decidí yo y socios
irnos a guadalajara que es el ecosistema
de emprendimiento que se parece a
silicon valley aqui en mexico
nacimos con muy poco dinero casi nada
comimos avena por meses arroz
hacer noches y días sin dormir
tenía un punto de quiebre espantoso
todos los días tengo que lidiar con la
frustración que todavía falta que
corregir muchísimos códigos muchísimos
problemas en el software
hace falta muchísimo tiempo para que
podamos alcanzar nuestra nuestra misión
y ha sido lo más complejo del mundo
imagínense tirar su trabajo de un mes
porque se dan cuenta de que no estaban
funcionando lo que hicieron porque
software un software no sabemos qué está
pasando que es que estamos haciendo no
es como los doctores que están en una
operación y tienen que saber que tienen
que hacer en el software no es así el
software es muy complejo como les digo
para ahorrar costos y hoy y socios
decimos estar en una casa de huéspedes
esta casa de huéspedes hay doctores hay
maestros de yoga hay de todo tipo de
personas guadalajara
yo decidí ponerme oficina en el lobby de
esta casa de huéspedes entonces cuando
entran las personas a las 7 de la mañana
me ven y estoy programando
lleguen a las 12 de la noche una a la
mañana me ven y yo estoy programando
entonces me apodaron el chico de la
computadora
pero yo no soy el único chico de la
computadora que hay mi socio que saben
en su cuarto también es el chico de la
computadora y guadalajara si se van a un
café van a encontrar a un chico otro
chico de la computadora con otro
problema totalmente diferente pero
completamente integra el entregado a
resolver un problema
todos pueden ser el chico de la
computadora
hay muchísimas personas especialmente en
guadalajara enfocados en hacer eso así
que yo creo que si ustedes definen muy
bien porque quieren resolver un problema
no importa el área donde sean no importa
si son de derecho no importa si son de
relaciones internacionales no importa si
son de medicina o bailarines
si ustedes tienen una computadora una
mesita y una conexión internet ustedes
también pueden resolver problemas
ustedes también pueden ser la chica o el
chico de la computadora
[Música]